hit podcast a slight change of plans
aims to help anyone out there trying to
navigate new challenges it's featured
conversations with big names like
hillary clinton tiffany haddish casey
musgraves and riz ahmed apple named the
show one of the best podcasts actually
not one of the best wow cast of 2021
that's a very big deal uh it has more
than four million downloads since its
launch last may and in the anchor chair
of that show is cognitive scientist maya
shunker she is the host and creator of
the podcast and she joins us now it's so
great to be here thank you very much for
being here uh was it a change of plans
that you arrived um
so this podcast is a hit i think in part
because it comes from a very personal
place for you uh tell us about that that
the the uh origin story for change of
plans yeah a slight change of plans
definitely comes from a very personal
place uh when i was a young kid i had
big dreams of becoming a concert
violinist and then a sudden hand injury
ended those dreams in a moment
and because my identity had been so
tethered to the violin for so long i
just remember feeling this huge void
within me and so in that moment i was
forced to redefine myself to try and
figure out who i was and who i could be
without the violin and that's really
what a slight change of plans is all
about it's about how those big changes
in life change us so so slight it's
really not a slight it's big yeah
it's a cheeky title it's a tiki title
uh so you've talked to regular people
you've got your own story you talk to
regular people uh you talk to famous
people yeah um so i'm curious have you
as you enter season three which debuted
i think on monday yes uh are there are
there similarities or commonalities
between otherwise different people
yeah i think that's been one of the most
heartening aspects of the show
which is that it is so easy for us to
see ourselves in the cast of characters
that are on a slight change of plans and
that's even the case when people's
change stories don't look exactly like
ours
and i think that's because there's this
underlying universality in the way that
we as humans respond to change how we
grieve in the face of change how we
problem solve in the face of change and
so you know i hear from listeners every
single day from all over the world who
are writing to me these heartfelt
letters saying you know this episode
really resonated with me that episode
really resonated with me and what i
found is that the resonance really
transcends circumstances so i i recently
heard from a recent divorcee who said it
was a cancer patient story that really
resonated with him and
a few weeks ago i heard from
a mother who tragically lost her 21 year
old son to a drug overdose and what she
shared with me is that it was my own
slight change of planned story so i
ended up sharing a very personal story
of my own on the show uh detailing how
my husband and i lost identical twin
girls to a miscarriage with our
surrogate and she said you know maya
even though the circumstances were very
different yours was the story that
really unlocked change within me that
helped me to
process my son's loss differently and to
really start start the healing process
yeah people connect with different
things when they listen um tony
mentioned season three congratulations
by the way thank you yeah i'm so excited
we were saying we're happy when we get
to wednesday
but one of the people you sit down with
is internationally renowned chef
christine ha what's so inspiring about
her story
yeah i mean christine had a total loss
of identity at this unexpected
unexpected moment in her life so
when she was in her early 20s she became
permanently blind
and it was around that time that she had
started cooking recreationally she was
eager to reconnect with her vietnamese
heritage and cooking was a vehicle for
her to do that and so when she lost her
vision she thought to herself i'm never
going to be able to cook again and
there's this really stirring moment that
she shares with me on a slight change of
plans where she's just trying to pull
together a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich she's like i've got this and
then suddenly she realizes there's jelly
that's running down her arm there's
jelly all over the table she can't line
up the slices of bread and she just
angrily tosses that sandwich into the
trash and thinks this is it i'm never
gonna be able to cook wow spoiler alert
she did cook again she does she crushed
it you guys okay she ended up winning
master chef the reality tv show
she yeah we gotta get going but you
crushed it thank you so much we're going
to continue talking after the break
we'll be right back